boy have i got a story for you
there's a lot a lot going on
with dayton hypernova so let me let me
catch you up on this is the past week
okay i have to catch you up
uh this is from the earl uh
dane hypernova you may know him as a
cade dorian paradoxa
or yeah head yep
skin boy yes laundry
okay and also that you could almost
laundry nicknames
i'm kind of doing the bruce buffer thing
where he just gives you 15 nicknames on
the fly yeah make you sound cooler
uh my so he put on his facebook my
parents got home in the middle of my
sleep
sleeping last night this morning my mom
tells me about an hour ago
they're moving my older brother to
hospice from a hospital in cincinnati
they don't know what to expect my mom's
tears were minimal today
and simply stating it's up to god now
with his condition
she was raised to show minimal emotion
about terrible things and to either be
empty about it or angry and gaslighting
the people around her
no actually i i hate to break this dear
earl but
the generations that came before
um had a very healthy tendency to
not display overwhelming amounts of
unnecessary emotion
like this is the problem with young
people nowadays is they think that
being a hysterical somehow
a good thing and it's like well no it's
not just because they're not
showing emotion doesn't mean that
they're not feeling the emotion but it's
best to not be hysterical oh i hate him
it's awful that these people are such
narcissist right-wing
christians uh dogmatist the mood in my
family is strange
and sour yet mildly serene and just
being neutral about what nursing
an alcoholic with more alcoholism does
after seven and a half years of him
living at home
the same place he's living yeah like you
you take that little dig like you're not
living a home too
wow if i move by spring or summer he's
not going to
this will be since we've covered him the
third time he said he's going to move
and it's been a long time a cover and
there's points yeah they're literally
going from having all the drama going on
in the house on a daily basis to total
silence
except to one another we continue the
story it's awful
i'm getting recordings today of as much
interaction through my family today as i
can
it doesn't even feel right but none of
it has felt right
and yet it is the only way to show
exactly how bad transphobia in america
still is in 2020
among relatives pause yes your [ __ ]
brother is dying
hospice yeah that's terrible like
none of the nothing else should matter
at that point your brother is dying like
trust me my family has its issues
they sure have their issues but you know
even
even my like i'm blown away by his
mental illness
and his selfishness because like i come
from a family of like
selfish drug addicted [ __ ]
narcissistic people but
and that's just mike that's just me um
but when you go to like a funeral in my
family right
like it's so rare that anybody in my
family makes it about them
makes it about their baggage or their
issues like like
when my nephew passed away one of my
sisters showed up to the funeral and i
was like
it was a flip of the coin i was very
like uh oh like
how is this gonna go like what is this
broad gonna bring in the door with her
and she even pulled it together for a
day and showed up
paid her [ __ ] respects and left like
hey earp if my family can do it
you could do it if you try if you just
try if you just maybe take one moment
out of the day and think of
anyone but yourself for five minutes you
can actually
let this day be about your brother in a
hospice
these are bigots who pretend nothing
horrendously wrong happens because of
them
in a word these are privileged people in
a society who cover the truth up
by behaving pretentiously in all matters
of violence and hate i have four
gigabytes of space on my ipad to record
he is now recording them we're waiting
with baited breath
uh okay so this is weird my parents both
drove down to cincinnati to visit
the skinhead son in the hospital how
about just he's in the hospital how
about just my dying brother
and they might not be home tonight
they'll text me to let me know if
they're coming home tomorrow
they sounded in tone like the house is
yours birthday boy it was his birthday
he is so
like i
i i i'm does that not bother you i don't
know of course
this whole like the difference is that
i've already read all this okay because
i hate him so much right now like i hate
him
so much right now uh the sound in his
tone
uh the sound they sounded in tone like
the house is yours birthday boy
they bought two full boxes of beer and
there's a big wine of son
of sangria multiple bottles worth this
is such this is all information you
should be focused on when your
brother's dying on the domino's website
i have a pre-free pizza
whoa big big man
if people are interested in having a
birthday party with me at my house
i have room for a few cars in my
driveway in the side street if you come
over it's your responsibility to protect
yourself from covid
i have a really strong immune system
because of my psoriasis
if you have a weak immune system best to
respect your help best respect your
health contact me if interested
can i can i break this down into a
quicker sure
my brother's dying and my parents left
so i'm gonna get a pizza and throw a
house party
yeah cool nobody liked this post by the
way
just so you know
and here it is this is from today this
morning
my older brother just passed away this
morning
his name was sherman anthony schultz
born may 29
1978. he passed away in a hospice in
cincinnati at age 42.
my mom my mom just walked into my room
crying and begging me not to drink too
much
as though she never even slightly
considered the possibility it could
cause harm
it's sad the culture we embrace of not
caring until it's way too late
the only good thing is that this will
slightly change my mom to a person who
doesn't ignore
suffering but i won't have anything to
do with her once i move out
what a sack of [ __ ] human [ __ ] this
guy is i'm so sick of him
i'm so [ __ ] sick of earl i really am
just
everything is me me me me me me your
brother's dead and it's still me me me
me me
me by the way 42 is young even if you're
a drunk
that's like and it was fast you know
from from hospital to hospice to death
this is this all happened within this
week this is all this week
i wonder what else there had to be
something wrong with him
um i can't just be
like liver failure at 42 unless he was
just
sucking down massive amounts of rock gut
booze on the reg
that that's a heart like 42 that's even
if you're a
full-blown alcoholic and drug addict
it's
very hard to be dead by 42.
so uh a lot of people are doing the
wrong kid dad
from dewey cox uh
so he he's moving he instead of when
something like this happens you get
closer to your family like you know
maybe i've you know you you kind of do
some you know
self-evaluating of the way you are me
you know maybe i'm i should honestly try
to be better with my family have a
better relationship you know
because life is very is very short and
anything could happen
instead he talks about that his mom's
going to be a better person we're not
done yet
well you what were you saying something
about like you know your family and
honoring your brother and
i got a free pizza on domino's though
huh
huh but how's sherman pizza time
sherman though pizza party and i love
two of these look i'm gonna throw a
party
i have one domino's pizza by the way
have you ever seen the free domino's
pizza have you ever seen the size of a
medium dominant of course
those things have shrunk so much over
the years that could you imagine going
to a house party
and earl is the host of the party and
there's one medium
domino's one topping on the table and
you're like this sucks
this [ __ ] stuff i could eat a
domino's medium by myself of course
any any normal adult man can order one
medium dominoes interesting
[Music]
well he continued after this this was at
9 00 a.m this morning
is when sherman passed away and then uh
this was uh
later on my ultra white ring mom just
told me that my phony pseudo-liberal
younger brother in seattle we got
another brother
we got another shells brother this is
like one this is like when a show
badly writes a character into the series
because it's like all right well we need
a
there was a third brother and you're
like okay so for three seasons nobody
talked about a third brother and then
suddenly there's a third
it's like they replace the duke boys
with their cousins yeah you're like
why don't you justify and you're like so
there's a new crowder out of nowhere
what is this
so my ultra right-wing mom just told me
that my phony pseudo-liberal younger
brother in seattle who has ignored
repeated attempts
by me to contact him by phone about the
skinhead beating me
and has this is after his brother died
by the way i love that whenever
this is the best most telling thing
about earl is
whenever he's explaining to you who
somebody is
it's still 15 sentences of me right like
that's that makes me laugh that [ __ ]
he's like yeah my younger brother who's
ignored repeated attempts his skinhead
beating me in my house
it's just me me me me beats me in this
house every time
i hate him uh my
uh about the skinhead beating me and has
not reached out to me whatsoever because
the drama of transphobia and feudalist
era racism
what are you [ __ ] samurai now all of
a sudden what is this [ __ ]
in our home yeah he follows
he follows the bushido code but like for
real though
no it's because my brother my skinhead
brother died and now
my younger brother is coming back
because he's a ronin and he no longer
has a master
like what is happening in our home
interferes with his perfectly non-caring
life which i have gotten beat again and
again since he first began ignoring my
outreaches to him
he's going to be here an entire week
because he's obviously going to the
funeral
uh [ __ ] this dude's pompous arrogance
when i told him in person i got beat in
our home in ohio
he told me shoutingly get a job i told
them
i have a job you do laundry so you're
you're you're lefty brother that lives
and so because i don't people you're my
right wing skinhead brother
your lefty seattle brother also hates
you yes
and i love too that he's like he's gonna
be spending a week here and it's like
yes he doesn't live there all the time
uh or did you know it's it's actually
normal behavior to visit a town because
somebody died in the family and stay at
a family member's house
that's a very normal thing now living
there for your entire life and expecting
them to do everything for you
and expecting to be paid at more than
minimum wage to do laundry
that's all abnormal earl but the whole
hey
uh i'm coming for sherman's um funeral
should i get a hotel and your family
going no i got plenty of room in the
house you come stay here
oh okay and he's acting like oh this
piece of [ __ ] is going to come here
for a week and it's like yeah yeah for a
week not forever
uh and yes someone pointed out the word
with purr point at night by the way nice
parks and rec reference says
notice the pseudo liberal so like a
regular liberal yeah
uh and one more this is this is after
his brother died
this is after his brother died i now
have video footage of inside my skinhead
brother's bedroom which i was once
beaten severely for even stepping inside
to take a laundry basket to do my below
minimum wage work cleaning clothes
it's bad in there megalomania
brother just died first of all pot meat
kettle
um wow
dude like you're you're just
like that's that's the kind of thing by
the way when somebody dies
it's nobody nobody should have the
instinct of i want to go in that
person's room like that's one of those
things where if you're a normal human
being
you don't go in that room for a while
right like you just kind of pass it and
go like
like if if my brother died or somebody i
were close to even if i didn't like them
or never died and i lived with them like
you'd walk past their bedroom and shut
the door and be like i don't want to go
in there for a while like
we'll deal with cleaning out that room
and stuff at another time but
you immediately went in there to snoop
around
and i'll bet she was looking for money
and like little i'll [ __ ] bet
of course probably stole his change jug
you know
probably his booze too probably um
the skinhead brother that b you know
what it is to go into your dead
brother's room the day he died and still
talk [ __ ] about
talk [ __ ] about him and make it about
you this whole
all these posts were about me me me me
me house party me me
my they're gonna be mean to me i'm still
not gonna speak to my mother me me me me
my other brother's coming me me me me me
here's what he did
it's it's i this is a god this
this i he is
irredeemable well you want to see what
he's been what he's doing
with all this stuff going on oh my god
you want to see what he's been up to
sure um i'm just
uh recording another video video on my
ipad here
um is it a second generation or a third
generation to show the progress
on what's it like
it's like a futon or whatever the type
of furniture
item like uh that i've transformed into
like kind of a sculpture that has a
spiral effect on it
and you know it does i took the cushion
off of it
to uh you know so basically it's just
all
the uh swirly great story hansel
thanks olaf aluminum
can i point out something
let's for those of you that don't
understand
this or grasp this
do do you people in the chat even have a
rough idea of how expensive aluminum
foil is
it's like it's one of those things you
never want to buy and when you do buy
you buy a giant roll
and you're like i don't want to have to
buy that again for a year
do you do again not stuff he's paying
for that means that he has been going
down and taking their aluminum foil
out of the kitchen and using it for his
worthless projects
i would be furious
i would be furious if i came back to my
place and somebody was like
oh i've been making sculptures with your
aluminum foil i'd be like
geometric costs do you know how much
aluminum foil costs like
you couldn't use something else i hate
him well but at least his brothers
was was you know dead or dying i think
his brother was dying when he made this
and people were asking and i'm sorry if
it wasn't clear sherman died of liver
failure they were actually before they
sent him to hospice
they were looking for a transplant and
they couldn't find one
to see you guys you know know well yeah
cause he's an alcohol he's still an
alcoholic and he's poor
like they're not gonna give you a
[ __ ] liver yeah you don't get the
best ones
kind of a glitter effect from the
aluminum and i'm thinking about
leaving like this uh
scent like this central area the spiral
the center very cool
but mike mike it's not cool
it's horrendous this you know what's
weird like this would be
probably the thing that made me beat him
to
if i were the father like of all the
other [ __ ] it would be this
the breaking point would be the aluminum
foil and then that's the kind of thing
where you're trying to explain it to the
cops later
in your statement and it makes you
sound crazy like it makes you sound like
the crazy one
like wait so you beat your son to death
because he made a sculpture with
aluminum foil and you're like
yeah but it's it's not just the sculpt
look look man
this dude's been a real [ __ ] pain in
my ass okay you're right
you're right like and the cops will be
going i have to arrest you you can't
just beat a man to death over aluminum
foil
and you're like no no you're twisting it
now making me
sound crazy jason fritz goes yeah but
you don't get is a spiral represents the
fibonacci sequence
oh nice it's pretty deep it's like tool
music
i'm not putting aluminum on that or if i
do put aluminum there
i might color it like so like trash
so so your art is just garbage that's
what it is
painted it it looks like the yard in
nothing but trouble
[Laughter]
fat babies are out there hot dogs
the fact that it's got that um
uh there's that what do they call it
there's a special word for like that
spiral effect
uh it's the uh mathematical spiral
effect
i was kidding with the fibonacci
sequence i was
kidding i swear to god i hadn't watched
this video and
obviously i haven't said the person in
the chat that said it they haven't they
couldn't have seen it because
nobody has this video
he's really trying to do the fibonacci
thing he's trying to bring your [ __ ]
trapper keeper
drawings to life he really he's going to
do the s you're going to do the s
you see it's like a really cool s and it
looks like almost like 3d
and i'm gonna do it with aluminum
um i'm gonna make i'm taking this
aluminum foil and i'm gonna make
a sculpture of the cars that you used to
draw in kindergarten
well you know his next one's gonna be
one of those kilroy was here once
your nose
[Laughter]
anyway um he's going to bring this to
the funeral
trying to pull it out trying to get it
out of the car that's why i'm laughing
hold on i'm gonna put i gotta put it
together there's two several pieces
this is first this is for you sherman
any is that a boom box and dusting of
insects
maybe you know we said it sounds like he
has sun chips in his pocket
maybe the reason it sounds that way he
was a little bit of oil
he's got a he's he's a walking faraday
cage
is he going to the funeral with this
with this tinfoil thing and then he goes
no i'd like to dedicate this art
performance
to my skinhead brother who beat me in
his room every day and then
he does a whole like interpretive dance
routine
with the sculpture behind him while al
cities
it's always a good time as playing in
the title it's going to be fireflies
we don't even have to try it's always a
good time
and he's just doing some weird like what
looks like
you know in the olympics when they do
the thing with the ribbon
right the ribbon whatever that is just
doing that in front of his stupid in
front of his stupid aluminum sculpture
and the whole family's embarrassed and
the mom and dad are going
actually frankly this is the best he's
ever been
this is him on good behavior oh [ __ ]
[Music]
sherman
you know what'd be awesome is if this is
all just one big
[ __ ] one big ruse and they're gonna
do this whole funeral
and then he's gonna go and he's gonna
start eulogizing his brother and
sherman's gonna
pop out of the coffin and just start
putting a can of whoop ass on them
how great would it be if this was all
just one long-form prank
they've gotten so sick of earl that
they're like let's do a whole
fake death we'll we'll send sherman to
cincinnati we'll put him up at the
marriott for a couple days
think about it it's so suspiciously fast
how he died
what if they just put him up in a
marriott in cincinnati and they went
don't come home for a couple days
and now they're gonna stage a funeral
earl's gonna show up with his [ __ ]
big foil statues
and sherman's gonna pop the lid open run
over and just
ground and pound the [ __ ] out of him
that's how i'm hoping this ends
the upside though now john mcafee has
another place you could do an interview
i mean my god
this place is a disaster it's an
unmitigated disaster
i believe uh i decided me and my black
prostitute wife
we've been snorting earl's skin flakes
they seem to have no psychoactive
chemical properties
oh my god about this
nature so that type of thing and i i
think very late at night right now so
i'm like not even
thinking or like like vividly on or
about your brother
your brother's dying you piece of [ __ ]
your brother just died and by the way
look i understand too that when
like people handle their grief
differently like i know personally i'm
the kind of guy like
if if i lose somebody close to me or
like i
i know people that will dive into their
work and i understand that but this
isn't work this is just you babbling
tinfoil in a in a [ __ ]
in an attic somewhere but completely
non-plus to this brother is dying
the terminology is on that but anyway
it's kind of you wouldn't understand it
the spiral that's kind of scary yeah i
told my parents had us everyone has a
liver i guess
or not i i like when he's like oh the
spiral means
like mathematically it's got a lot of
significance yeah i know it was one of
the first things ever drawn on a cave
wall calm down [ __ ] morocco literally
one of the first things men ever did was
one
i drew a swirl and everybody was
impressed it kind of just goes with
everything
um so you've ruined an entire box of
aluminum foil
uh excuse me several boxes of aluminum
foil and now you've also ruined the
attic
right okay okay so i hope you're happy
everything has been ruined
his [ __ ] frank underwood's typewriter
apparently too
the old typewriter that's a century old
that i bought online years ago
he buys garbage he buys great he just
buys trash
he fills the attic with [ __ ] ebay
trash like you'd almost be better off
having a
kid that like goes out and does drugs
and parties
than this this is just worse
just really you know a far out style
what it's far out hey far out man
hey why don't you get a job man
first let's see what it looks like
though there anyway i wanted to do a
video of this yeah i was just
upstairs talking to earl man i don't
think he knows his brother is sick or
anything man
it's just like acting like nothing's
going on dude what if that's a seattle
brother what if a seattle
sounds just like that is based hippie
yeah yeah
just talk about it yeah i used to live
in dayton too man there's just too many
too many i feel like you know they all
know about dave chappelle
man and they're all moving here now
getting
closer to finish with this uh part this
stop saying finish as if there's a
beginning a middle and an end stop
saying
finish like this is a project you know
what i mean like this isn't like a
it's a project this isn't two window
washers on a [ __ ] skyscraper in new
york and you go
hey when are you guys gonna be finished
and you go i'll probably in about eight
hours
it's gonna take us that long to get this
actual project done
he's like i don't know what it's going
to be i love when somebody's like
literally just collecting garbage in an
attic and they're like yeah i don't know
when it's going to be finished
what's finished so this is a newer one
this is now this isn't finishing
there's no audio oh my god what's
happening
i think he sped it up like
[Music]
warhol inspired see this he has his
warhol inspired
yeah well i wish you wish you were even
more inspired by andy warhol
now there's your dayton update for the
people who are looking i [ __ ] hate
him
so much he's just you're intimidated by
that out of
all of the people we cover i think he's
got to be the worst
oh yeah for sure he's the worst he's
worse than those other weirdo meth heads
uh the psychic vampire yeah dashing the
psychic vampire dashed in the psychic
vampire at least is a meth problem like
at least you could
you could try to at least envision what
they'd be like not on meth
as opposed to rope who it's you're just
like this this is how you are just like
this